foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you yep
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
we're waiting for our guests
thank you
[Music]
what's going on guys
welcome back to the attic show we've
talked about the past present future
gaming I got my co-host with me Dirk
Gregory what's going on Dirk griggity
what's up brother how you doing doing
pretty good man you know we uh we got
some stuff to talk about as you guys
could see there was a topic on the
agenda that uh you know most likely
under regular circumstances we probably
wouldn't have talked about but I do
think this is one of those incidences
where we need to address it to some
degree uh so we'll get into that uh we
we do have kids smooth here but I don't
know what happened to him uh he he's
lost in the abyss somewhere I'm sure
he'll get to us eventually but
appreciate it for coming through you
know we're going to be talking about
some some some Xbox buying influencers
yeah and then we're gonna be talking
about apparently there's no demand for
Banjo-Kazooie and then we're going to be
talking about Xbox at Gamescom they've
confirmed they're going to be there
that's what you've been playing Dirk
what's what's been on the agenda uh
I've um
I went back tried to finish got them
nice that's what I've been playing and
and a little
I'll be kind of messed with three games
got them nice Diablo 4 and um in a
little cyber crunk but yeah but right
now I think I'm towards the end and got
them nice I just want to finish that one
up it's not a bad game it's definitely
not great but it's not bad
um yeah so I'm going to finish that one
up soon then I do want to finish up
cyberpunk before September because you
know September is all about Starfield so
yeah starf is going to be a
one hell of a show man I've been playing
Final Fantasy 16. that's pretty much
that's okay
you know I'm not gonna say it's like the
best game in the world but it's
definitely not the worst game of the
world I I do think that you know if you
like a catchy game if you like a very
good looking graphical game this game is
for you but if you like final fantasies
and you're going into this expecting a
Final Fantasy
that's when this game is not for you I I
do think that you know there's Final
Fantasy fans like such as myself that
enjoy it but I wouldn't go as far as say
this is a Final Fantasy game because I
don't I don't I don't think that's
accurate right
I got you let's just move's over there
uh I don't know what he's doing he
you're muted
you're muted on uh on this uh on on Zoom
I think he's talking someone in the
background though oh I don't know who
he's talking to but anyway yeah we we
gotta go what I'm saying you got me
muted yeah because yeah we're live yeah
that's why I'm using you
oh damn
okay I got a schedule
no the reason it's the reason I went uh
live is because dirt got to be on um on
on fames podcast at seven so I'm trying
to get him out here at 6 30.
all right so 6 30 you just need like 6
like 60 yeah okay where the conversation
is we'll dip in where the conversation
is all right chat share this out man
cause we about to get into this Xbox
buying
influencers and I brought smooth in here
because we're all Xbox influencers to
some degree I would say I'm a little bit
more of a uh not necessarily neutral but
I talk about a little bit more variety
of stuff than the rest uh kids who talk
about I don't even know what he'd be
talking about half the week so uh
sometimes you tell he does strictly
stick to games but sometimes smoothly
going around about white Square Enix is
trash so you know uh we're gonna go
ahead and get into this because there's
been a lot of things going on that is
mind-blowing to me so first let's get
over all let's go to dirt because
because yeah because there were some
shots directly shot at dirt so I want
him to get his his uh his bars off you
know explain exactly you know how you
feel about that because I feel like the
reason that I want to let you go wild on
this obviously that don't go wild wild
but right it's like I want you to get
your Ballers across because it's like
people were acting like
you were just like putting there's like
a token black guy and like yeah it
didn't matter how long you've been
grinding how long you've been doing this
you're talking black guys so we're going
we're going to get you up in there we're
gonna get you views who cares you've
been doing this for six seven years yeah
go ahead man the the stage is yours well
first off I want to say what's up the
kids movie Man homie kids movies
what's up man because you know I know I
don't know if you heard it he brought
your name up first
so you did here okay he said smooth was
the the token black guy I can't hear you
what'd you say
he said I'm not as big
no no what I heard him say he said Xbox
didn't like you anymore because you
criticize them so they said you know he
said he wasn't as big at first he did
say that yeah yeah yeah that's the first
part he said but then he said uh smooth
critic he criticized Xbox too much so
they needed another black another black
to come into to the scene and that was
me and I'm like what is this guy talking
about
you know it pisses me off because I mean
it's funny but at the same time it
pisses me off because like you said I've
been doing this for six years man it's
not like I just came out of nowhere you
know actually I'm gonna give kids smooth
props the first person ever asked me
to be a guest on on a podcast was kids
move
I was green as hell I um
it might have been early days of playing
Xbox it was early days of playing it was
I part of the panel
I don't remember you being there I
remember that frog guy was there yeah
okay then I probably was it either that
or it was like right after I left Planet
Xbox okay yeah so um so
okay it's more the first person I ever
asked me on this podcast so this stuff
it just shows how these guys are
I don't understand where they're
they're just losing it in my mind
they're losing it some of the things
they're coming up with and I know this
all started from that wild that World of
Warcraft X the X World of Warcraft
developer he said some stuff and that
caused the PlayStation Fanboys to run
you know what's funny
the majority of these PlayStation people
know were not bought
but it's funny it gave them content
yeah
but I mean but then you got guys
explaining the pictures saying there's
not all of those plates at the table
who's taking the picture I mean come on
bro
all right this is what we're going to do
all right I'll go do this on IOP too I
want you guys in the chat to put kids
smooth dirt
an addict and put what you think
Microsoft paints I want you guys to tell
me what you think our value is to
Microsoft so put in the chat what you
think all of us individually be paying
imma tell you if if I would sell out for
that number so let's let's let's
continue Dart while they put that in
there oh man
um so not like I was mentioning you know
I did a video about this topic and I was
like bro I remember first starting doing
a video editing the video and get 60
views bro so you can't tell me I didn't
pay my dues and guess what even when I
wasn't getting many views I was still
Pro Xbox because that's who I am in real
life you know this isn't a game I'm not
one of these flip-floppers that rep Xbox
for four years and then all of a sudden
flip to the PlayStation side and then
want to come back to that no that I'm
genuinely a Xbox fan so
this guy's saying people are pushing uh
us man he actually put me in a category
with you know Iron lures with Rand with
dealer
I said damn thanks for putting me in the
category with those guys you know what
I'm saying
I hate you I hate YouTube said one
million for dirt five dollars for
attitude smooth
oh my God so is he saying you are the
token black guy because like how how do
you pay one that not the other one
someone said 50 G's would you if
Microsoft hit you up today dirt it was I
give you 50 G's you shop for Xbox keep
in mind you're already yeah a year keep
in mind you already
putting that to some degree would you
take that video would you take that
listen yeah because I I'm doing it and
they're not even giving me any money so
yeah of course I would yeah I ain't
gonna lie to you man like I'm a little
offended that
that uh I ain't got that money where my
money at
if ran and coat is is cashing out
you know I I'd be seeing where is my
money at it's like I told you man USPS
we have beef
and you know what's so funny though
this guy said me and I don't even have
10 000 subscribers yet bro why in the
hell would Xbox be paying me
I don't have a 100 000 subscribers or
something why would they be paying me
I'm close to ten thousand but I don't
even have ten thousand subscribers man
they said jtex set smooth does it for
free
that's so smooth you know
um I got this because dirt dirt said he
was let in the house because he was
black I got you because they said you
weren't big enough and dirt replaced you
in in the house so how do you feel about
these allegations going on
oh man it's all nonsense the thing is uh
what what it is it is is that if
somebody's weirdos like and I've said in
my original tweet about reforge gaming
and uh the grubs guy I don't care where
the hell he worked and what he did he's
a failure because he's not doing it now
so that's all that that's all I mean to
me if you were you you did something
once that was successful and you ain't
doing it now and you're on Twitter
arguing with us you're a failure I'm
sorry
um
so the thing is is that how I perceived
it is that okay
He barked up the wrong tree people come
into this community to get big the
problem is they come in with like some
sort of following but it's not the
following isn't big in their current
state but they can
quadruple that following if they enter
the console Ward right so
he comes in
says what he says obviously we're going
to respond and he wasn't ready for the
smoke so once he got all the smoke it
just went oh these are paid Bots or
they're like spam accounts that
Microsoft is buying like really and then
all these PlayStation fanboys who've
been arguing with us for damn near a
decade buys into this right like really
like like and the whole thing with like
red dragon by not saying all this stuff
I'm like bro are you serious dude it was
like the thing is what happens is with
the PlayStation guys is that they always
feel some type of way when they see us
uh at events or we're taking pictures
with like Phil Spencer and that's right
Matt booty Sarah bonding all the stuff
and we're engaging with them it's not
our fault that he
Xbox execs are social
so we're social if we're we engage with
them so when when they see us taking
these photos or going out to events they
assume like this is paid so technically
I can technically say yes Xbox pays me
because my YouTube is built off Xbox
content and I get paid from YouTube ad
revenue and that's Xbox content XBox
doesn't pay me but I'm technically being
paid for doing Xbox content because
that's what I chose to do when I created
a YouTube channel so um the thing is is
I think it's a little bit of jealousy
envious and then people are hurt because
obviously there's a lot going on with um
you know the Xbox and you know if this
APK deal goes through there people are
just preparing for the pain yeah and um
they're just trying to get themselves in
line I just don't appreciate
um
the comment the notion because it's all
Bs and I don't like how many people are
buying into it
um I don't like these these new guys
that are coming into the community and
trying to make a stamp like as if
they're they got to be some automatic
respected person uh for us to like oh
you said this oh you because you worked
on World of Warcraft like I gotta
respect everything you say no just
because reforge had like a destiny
following used to be a streamer got
kicked out the community and he he
landed into the Crump side I gotta
follow him because he's uh his his
videos are are clean you know what I
mean and the thing is that PlayStation
Fanboys what they do is they cling on to
anybody that's critical of Xbox when
they invite these newbies who don't play
video games at all into the community
and just and just pretty much at the
chamber what they're saying and you know
what's funny like King Philip in this
army man you know we we got we got dirt
with the second string with the arrows
behind us and you'll keep building this
Army
and these PlayStation fans keep
snatching the new cut the new Xbox
people and spit them out before they
become an Xbox Channel like they they
try to get my dude dirt over there but
he is like he broke it he broke the line
like nah man Hey listen I hope people I
hope people see why my channel was like
it is right I've been there going to
PlayStation podcast chatting with those
guys I've been on podcasts where there
are several PlayStation guys and two
XBox guys and I'm one of them I've been
there I've interacted with ponies I've
debated them on podcasts I've debated
them on Twitter I'm done with that
when I tell people I loathe all of them
people say there come on man calm down
no no no I don't want to talk to them
y'all not welcome in my chat y'all not
welcome on my channel and you see this
Behavior
is what I'm talking about man these
people up here saying that
Microsoft is paying us because
the Xbox Executives actually rock out
with the community they actually tweet
they actually follow some of us they
talk to us when we go to a Fan Fest they
take pictures
go to dinner lunch or whatever
and they have problems with that like to
the point they're questioning why are
there so many plates on the table
questioning who's taking the picture
come on man it's crazy and you know the
crazy part too is like people are
sharing you know the picture that we
took of fire in greenbird me Cog Cole uh
there's a couple of other prominent
people uh you know um
bunch of people I I can't even there's
so many there's like eight people and oh
Aaron's there he paid for it he paid for
the launch that that that's the meeting
that's the meeting first off if I'm
being bought on Microsoft they're not
taking me to breakfast they're taking me
to dinner okay I'm getting a steak
I'm getting the mashed potatoes that I
don't like
okay they do a more than just breakfast
guys we getting we getting fed fed uh
this is how that went you know we just
tell them they're eating breakfast so
we're waiting to go to the event and
Aaron Greenberg was walking down the
hall and he saw us and he came over and
we talked for a couple minutes and he's
like well I gotta go uh you know hope
you guys have a good show and he's like
let me get a quick picture obviously
he's a marketing dude he's going to
that's good marketing for him but it's
like at the same time it's like you know
even if he did pay for that dinner that
ain't none of your business
but he didn't you want to get technical
that bill was split three ways
it's like I mean people you know they
they can say what they want they can
think all day until they until they face
turns blue that like I'm a corporate
shot I don't care because I've been
waiting to sell out I just ain't been
able to yeah
so we gotta find out from rain G4 okay
here we go guys let's see what people
think they paying us people super
chatting it let's go
Alex getting 10K every tie he Praises
Xbox
so am I getting 10K every time I praise
Xbox in general or is it just 10K a
month if I praise Xbox you have to be
more specific on that one dirt to uh to
gay black Gamers 10K
it's smooth to put Game Pass accounts in
his kid's name foreign
getting paid 2500 a week and they pay
his rent kids smooth they put him on the
health insurance plan at least come on
man
don't don't eat that don't don't take
that bait smooth because they they try
to get you man they try to get you try
to get a a reaction from you find out a
screw track for rank G4 kids uh kid
smooth eating a steak dinner as we just
discuss as we discuss whether or not
he's getting a bag from Xbox is that
steak
it is steak
oh wow you guys realize steak's like not
that expensive right like no people take
that stake and they make it very like
what's what I'm looking for
very premium like and that's why you pay
like crazy amounts of steak and they get
imported State like
steak itself at the store it's not that
expensive
my broke ass can go out and buy steak
all right so uh then we got two dollar
supercharge from Ray Ray
Darkness gets paid his Xbox points
if right now Phil switch to hit you up
dirt and smooth you answered this too
and like dirt smooth we want you to
Shell for Xbox
we're gonna give you a code for every
cane that comes on the Xbox platform
third party Indies first party all of it
but you gotta do it for 10 years would
you do it
I I've been doing it for 20 of us but
but you can't you can't leave once you
agree you locked in for 10 years
of course I'm doing anyway
that's not an issue I do it yeah does it
make it different it doesn't change what
I'm doing now right I'm actually doing
it now you know what's funny is like we
take the bag we just ain't getting the
bag
it's like it would probably take me
50 G's a year I I
already make the content so it's not
like it's going to bother my content uh
but if they legitly and I don't think
you know I do think that some
PRS are very strategic to how they do
stuff but I don't think they come out
straight and say you have to make this
type of content like it would be one of
those things where it's like you have to
make a certain amount of content on this
I don't think that would ever come out
and try to dictate the content you make
but at the end of the day Microsoft
isn't doing stuff like that I mean think
about
think of how much money that would cost
we're talking about one individual
person
yo you might get us for 50 60 G's just
because I'll be extra playing around
money but if you want people that
actually can make a difference
we talking two three hundred thousand
easy
and that that adds up really really fast
you know I don't think that they I think
they prefer to give people as much free
product as possible to see this one
that's really easy you know I wish they
would have instead of paying out like
all those streamers to go to mixer I
wish they would have paid a bunch of
content creators just to do like the
stuff we're doing now like I don't need
the ninja money but I would have taken
like
I'm gonna take it uh like a six
weeks promotional thing okay six month
promotional thing from 10K I'd be all
right I'm gonna flip it on you guys I'm
gonna flip it on you guys
Jim Ryan
comes up to you and he like 100 G's a
year would you flip go to PlayStation
content no 100 years a year it's a new
salary I can quit my job
it's a new salary like you know what I
mean well I do YouTube content for a
place a thousand dollars yeah absolutely
so you'd be you 'd be a PlayStation
a PlayStation content create but you
have to be toxic
yeah it's easy
you
that's really easy I couldn't do it
because my because my content would be
trash because it would be fake oh yeah
the content will probably the drop off
would be yeah I can't say that it will
be quality content but I do it if you're
willing to pay me a hundred thousand
dollars a year yeah yeah I'll talk about
PlayStation
what people don't realize
about
us me Dirk and um and a few others that
they think we sit around talking about
PlayStation all day we don't the problem
is because we're always constantly
arguing what places your Fanboys they
talk about places your Fanboys it comes
off as if we're talking about
PlayStation it's like no it's the people
when it meets like I don't count Final
Fantasy that's that's squirting that's
my beef with Square Enix I don't care
that is exclusively on please um
PlayStation that's my beat okay okay
100 G's you got to make Square yes
I can do that too you got to play the
games too
that's gonna be hard
oh my god let's get these super chats
and uh you know we'll end this topic and
go on to the next one
uh no offense to anyone find out Super
Range G4 appreciate the Mad support man
uh but if you have act like Lamar Wilson
no offense to him just joking I don't I
I think that's a football player but I'm
not quite sure no that's the YouTuber
he's a black YouTuber I don't I don't I
don't know these these people's names
and
you know Lamar Wilson smooth yeah yeah
he's paid like he's great that's that's
what Lamar Wilson he sounds like a
football player they'll offer like is it
is there a Lamar in the foot in the NBA
or NFL Jackson there's a bunches yeah
yeah yeah see I don't know I don't know
yeah Lamar was he's been around a long
time I ordered dude uh he does a lot of
unboxing videos yeah and um but he's a
person actually that probably is I can
I'd say 90 yeah he's actually paid as
like one of those content creator type
deals so um I found he was paid by a
bunch of uh like Publishers and people
are releasing devices I've received
remember the random controller unboxings
that some of us do we get small time
bills like that he just get it at a
bigger level
yeah so I was I was going around and I
found this
it's a uh it's like a game it's GameCube
controller yeah
it's a wired one I gotta find a cord for
it but I could play the Zelda games with
it
good old GameCube yeah
yeah so my favorite consoles okay this
is a since they have did you see that uh
that fan funding thing dirt where you
could just see nothing but super chats
members and stuff
that
um no well if you click the little arrow
in your chat when you're doing your
podcast it'll go down you know I used to
say live and and chat oh yeah yeah yeah
but on YouTube yeah there's a third one
now called uh it's called fan funding
and it just shows you super chats
members because sometimes it's hard to
keep up in the chat like because they'll
be going up in the but this only has
that like so you only see those so it
makes things a lot easier uh so just so
you guys know I don't really see the
chat that's the only thing I've seen
nothing against you guys I just got to
make sure I get these I'd be missing
this sometimes and I feel bad
um two dollars super uh two dollar Super
Chat from
I don't know is it me or the PS guy just
kidding fired back for eight years
straight
I don't backfire he's just K JK
I have no idea joke isn't jk just joking
yeah that's usually what it is I'm just
kidding the final subscribe for the
angry therapist part of me truly
believes they are jealous because Sony
don't engage with their fans I agree uh
you know
I will say that there are some that take
that like the executive thing a little
bit too far but I will say that if you
go out there and you're saying some
really sus stuff but you've never really
had conversations with these people or
anything like I've actually talked to
the majority of the executives I've
talked to Phil Spencer I've talked to
Sarah Bond I've talked to Aaron
Greenville on multiple occasions I I've
talked to a variety of those people
Aaron Greenberg has helped me get
multiple review codes
so it's just like they they are truly
trying to help their Community you know
do we take it a little too far sometimes
you know I know I know a certain podcast
here that gave Phil Spencer a Divine
name
but it's all jokes you know Phil Dominus
Maximus Spencer it's all it's all jokes
nothing is took it should be tooken
seriously you know there's a line
between entertainment and informative
information and we tried to stay in the
middle as much as possible
see but they don't know the difference I
I saw a recent clip of somebody calling
out King David for saying hold the line
he said don't hold the line draw the
line ask for better Xbox if you draw the
line King is just going to use the
Cavalry and just go straight through the
line yeah
like King has got a structure man he's
got a whole mental fortification how
he's gonna take your front line you know
it's it's like the old days man the
Spartans whatever whoever they fought
I'm not a history buff but you know you
got the line you're holding the line on
this side you're holding the line on
this side let me tell you right now the
PlayStation channels they're not forming
a line they got like three people
there is way more prominent Xbox
channels that you can watch because
trust me I've looked for good
PlayStation channels to bring it on the
show to bring it on on a variety of
things you know me and kids smooth are
going to work on getting uh columnar
already on planet Xbox because you know
smooth wants he wants to ask you
questions
so it's just like you know even though
how ridiculous call it could be
sometimes I would consider him more of a
more balanced PlayStation dude than some
of these crazy dudes walking around are
um
we got a five dollar Super Chat from uh
from Cipher pole 92 Real Talk aren't we
all flipping uh flipping for the for the
for the bag I'd take the money and start
dancing with
five dollar subscribe from Corey Tidwell
dirt damn dirt happy to see you and kids
move with uh still cool after you
replaced him as the token okay I'm not
saying that you yeah
look man
Dirt has put in his time he he he ain't
no token nothing okay he we we we we
have chosen him as as our right wing
he he he he is one of he is one of
general of command General Kings
commanders okay hey and this is funny
though I'm like so man listen
I was in the bed I was about to fall
asleep somebody hit me in the damn like
dirt bro listen to this he clipped it
out
and I was just like why is he mentioning
me
Dirk Gregory has got to push somebody's
pushing him
what are you talking about man yeah and
you know what that is that's jealousy
that's jealousy that we have over 400
people in our chat right now and most of
them people can't get more than 50. now
obviously there are PlayStation you know
MBG I don't like to do for the most part
I think you know his content is is
ingenuous what is it
you know it is what it is if you could
get that many people to come every week
to your nonsense opinions then by all
means do it like just do it like I don't
even at this point get your bag I'm not
even hating if you've got convinced that
many people to hold the line for you you
need to hold that line
oh God two dollars subscribe from Ray
Ray no dirt it's a bot father nah come
on man don't say that you know how many
people are gonna like clip that out say
that you're the boss all right so you
know we're going to move on from that
you know it's like I said I think a lot
of that's just not necessarily jealousy
it's I think it's a combination of
jealousy and
miscommunication I'm just hey hey I'm
gonna tell you exactly what it is I'm
gonna tell you exactly what it is some
of these guys because I've heard them
say this before some of the Die Hard
PlayStation guys
um I told a story where I I went to a
Playstation podcast this was the last
time I ever was a guest on the pony
podcast this was 2019 I believe last
time I was ever guest
and I got pretty much cross-examined
by this guy on the panel I will tell you
guys exactly who it is later he said
dirt
why are you Xbox fan I said what do you
mean he said how can you
oh my God okay okay go ahead my bad
yo
what what
happened
oh okay let me let me show you
you guys gonna have to see it on um on
the stream in a couple seconds look what
someone did
yeah
yo I gotta give people a very very
clever
[Laughter]
I'm dying a little bit inside that was
funny that was funny yeah yeah I think
my boy Joy did that yeah um go ahead and
finish so so like I was saying so the
guy pretty much
um grilled me like yo man wow your Xbox
fan all that because I love the brain he
was the how how can you and he was dead
serious like how can you possibly love
Xbox over PlayStation and I said what do
you mean bro I like the Xbox ever since
the original rest but he's like nah I'm
not buying and he really could not
fathom that I love the Xbox more on the
PlayStation so my point was saying well
guys like uh you know the other guy that
that accused us of of all being paid his
his logic his mind thinks like Xbox is
so trash
nobody really likes Xbox I mean he
actually said that nobody really likes
Xbox they're being paid to say positive
things about Xbox because nobody in the
world really likes Xbox
so what world do they live in I'm
telling you I'm these guys are
delusional yes PlayStation sells more
but there's still people that like the
Xbox brand right yes clearly but in
their minds no no no no of course y'all
I really don't like Xbox because Xbox is
trash look up with the most profitable
um
fast food join us look at that for me I
don't know if it's McDonald's or Subway
oh it's definitely McDonald's I looked
this up the other day it's McDonald's
that's like that mindset is like saying
okay McDonald's is so on top Subway
Wendy's Taco Bell KFC they just need all
go out of business so we all eat at
McDonald's every day that's their logic
that's their logical
these guys but I'm telling you man these
guys the the arrogance
see this is that they they're not used
to this they're not used the Xbox
being aggressive and making big moves so
now they're just like wait a minute
something ain't right these Xbox
YouTubers like Dirk griggity he's
actually his channel was actually
growing he gets decent numbers for a
channel his size something's not right
because there's no Xbox fans that's
really watching this dude I'm telling
you this that's these guys attitude man
it's crazy and you know what I've
noticed the two
um XBox channels generally grow quicker
because we have more
influence on YouTube then I've seen a
lot of PlayStation like the PlayStation
ecosystem on YouTube it's big but as far
as like this side of the YouTube it's
not as big you got people like Cody
Eastwood brand you know when you keep
going on the their shows you keep
getting constant at exposure IOP grew
like 2 000 Subs last month yeah so it's
like when you take that into
consideration like you know Derek's been
doing this show for me a while I'm sure
I've I've drove in a lot of traffic to
his because they like his Vibe so it's
just like but a lot of these PlayStation
people they're just in like a little
circle they never talk to anyone they
just social network which is them and
you're not seeing that growth because
there's not as many big people in the
PlayStation hemisphere does that make
sense
yeah definitely
all right so let's let's get to Super
Chat and we'll go move on uh we don't
need to talk about this uh two dollar
super trap
LA Queen
laquoon
all you're talking about Joaquin Ranch
uh like yeah what he said uh Lulu
let me get it where she
dirt yo boy King thrash has lost it oh
he's saying that's your boy King my boy
this is the exact opposite actually
all right so let's let's get on to this
Banjo-Kazooie apparently so apparently
like I think it was like an old Dev or
something or someone from like rare
something from a prominent thing said he
doesn't personally feel like actually
let me get the uh
let me get the um
the
ah I completely messed up
whatever
all right so 48 minutes and 20 seconds
oh man I I can't be after you you know
what's funny is I I didn't put the Xbox
influence thing as a as a uh
as a copy oh you can do that later yeah
so I'm just wait wait do we start
talking influencers
nah these everyone's gonna suffer with
me all right so let's let's talk about
this so apparently there's no
competition there there's no growth or
you know they don't think there is a
market for Banjo-Kazooie I'm gonna throw
my little thing real quick like my
little sentence I'm gonna give a broader
statement later after the rest of the
panel goes
I'm just saying if Ratchet and Clank has
an audience there's no way in hell a
well thought of well-designed
banjo-kazoo we would continue
um I think if they're going to bring
banjo back they should do a remaster
first just to see the reception
completely the seat of reception before
jumping into a sequel they should do a
remaster first just to see how people
respond to it that's what I would do and
not a not just a 4K 60 update just make
like you know a nice little remake I
should say
shouldn't shouldn't be that expensive to
do a nice little remake
do you think that
here's my thing
even if it doesn't have a
an audience I say or say
isn't the whole point of doing the Game
Pass model is to taking more risks
because you have a little bit more back
income coming in so to me even if that's
the case it's not an excuse not to try
it
you know I agree with that I think if
you did a very high I would love AAA
Banjo-Kazooie but I doubt that's ever
gonna happen no but I would take a very
high Prof High budget double A like
right there when you go from a double A
to a triple A I I think that you remake
Banjo-Kazooie from the ground up
modern Graphics maybe put a couple more
levels in there just to show what you
could do because if you stick towards
for the original script you're going to
have really like weird transitions
you know uh because you're trying to
keep it to what it was back then and
it's going to be hard to do that as well
as to show you what a banjo three would
look Badger Kazooie four or three if you
could count nuts and bolts so I feel
like you do a base game you do both of
them magic Kazooie and banjo too we
remake them from the ground up because
you already have the game there and then
in both games
you make like a an extra world that you
show okay this is up until now and I it
would be cool imagine if you did the
whole Banjo Kazooie world right you beat
the game
and then there's a there's a hidden
level and they walk in there and this
text I pop up and it says this is what
the future of magical zoo we could look
like and it shows you like newer
gameplay mechanics going in this world
well I mean you I mean that would be
cool but I think you really couldn't do
that unless you're committed to it you
can't tease people
unless you're gonna do it you know what
I'm saying I feel you about the same
time
something like that would catch people
off guard and would get a lot of Buzz
going
it would it would and in order for you
to be successful they're going to have
to get that buzz you know one thing you
could say about Ratchet and Clank ripped
apart in the the 2018 one or 16. I can't
remember what year that game came out is
they were graphical show pieces you have
to have the same thing you know you
can't just come in there and just have
platforming you got to have either a
narrative with that which most
Platformers don't have really well
thought of narratives and you gotta have
or you got to be graphically intense I
think your best bet is to make remake
the original one and be graphically
intense
yeah I mean
see the only thing that I'm cautious
with at it we've heard so many things
over the years not just Xbox we heard
some PlayStation people scream about a
certain game okay perfect example
people's like where's the Last Guardian
where's the Last Guardian PlayStation
brought that game out shoulder that E3
was it 2015 the first game they show
people went crazy yeah the last time
yeah Playstation One E3 that game came
out and sold 1300 copies man nobody
bought the damn game right there's other
examples I can't think of off the top of
my head of games that that people want
it we can't wait man bring this game
back bring it back and then the game
release and nobody cared so
I think the only way to do with this one
first they have to make
oh like a remake not a not a rematch to
put a remake okay you know let me throw
a little caviar in there they remake
Banjo-Kazooie let's see whatever
what's moose said they remake
Banjo-Kazooie 2024 Shadow drops to say
E3 next year whatever you want to call
that that event right
the Microsoft acquisition goes through
they buy blizzard
they buy Activision they buy King
spiral comes out in 2025
it has Cameo Banjo-Kazooie in it
and then the next game is them together
in a game
you said Spyro and banjo no I meant uh
Crash Bandicoot and banjo oh okay okay
listen those are two different like type
of games out there you know banjo plays
what like freaking Mario 64 or something
yeah obviously you do that same engine
it seemed like yeah you would have to
one would have to be like
it would have to be both of them in one
of them's I think banjo-kazooie's world
would work a little bit more like the
type of game that Banjo-Kazooie makes
now obviously you could bring banjo in
the type of world that you know Crash
Bandicoot is but I feel like you put
Crash Bandicoot and you put banjo in the
same game in a very well done way
it's going to bring a lot of attention
to it
I think um banjo I think the developer
right there isn't a market for banjo
there might be a market for like
platforms but there was barely a market
for Ratchet rat people front like just
because Ratchet and Clank released it
didn't sell that great hey hey smooth
you're speaking fast it was a beautiful
game I think it's so like maybe a
million
yeah I mean maybe that's decent for a
platformer but I think they drive
wrestling you're right exactly but I
think they they drop wrestling too she's
about to mute you guys about the Mewtwo
suckers a beautiful a beautiful game for
the PS5 that's what I've that's what I
really think yeah
why can't I get my banjo why you and
guys like Cody school got to come in
here POS you got to sit on the shelf and
say Adam we don't care what you want
banjo was a POS addict once if Andrew
came out and successful
uh I will I will I would prefer another
crash another Spiral hell anything I
prefer anything besides patch banjo POS
hi yeah I would I would I would I would
prefer a Winnie the Pooh game no I'm
joking
you know what what
are you doing another show
what are you doing another show
in a few man in a few but what do you do
in another show what's your next show
are you doing the solo show or what's
your next show
the homie oh oh oh oh always on my mind
next show yeah I got the solo show on
Thursday you know what guys we have 466
people in here first off hit that like
button appreciate all of you coming
through got a two dollar Superstar from
jax82
bring back banjo and spiral the dragon
that's cool yeah you know dirt's a hater
he's drinking the whole thing of
haterade uh I'm joking
if your next show what what do you
normally let's see hold on let's see
what dirt
s
let's go to dart's channel real quick
I'll be roasting like my last few a few
videos I was roasting ponies yeah let's
let's look at this okay
we're about to do this live because
because I'm serious
so here's Dirk's Channel
I would prefer a conquer
over uh banjo see here I prefer Cameo
elements of power Cameo was actually a
pretty dope game Brother people really
kind of slept on
all right he's doing that uh that x uh
that his solo show tomorrow I I don't
say the name uh because uh one man dark
man yeah I would say that uh I want you
all to show up to that and what what's
your last one man dark man hold up
which one my last woman dark man was the
one with Ace Xbox versus FTC huge
decision next week all right first and
give you a like
uh
uh you have
531 likes if you get 800 likes your next
one would you stream Banjo Kazooie
yes
no
800 likes
gotta do it for the culture man you got
to do it for the culture
banjo you got to do it for the culture
800 likes
that's a lot I I cannot commit to
streaming banjo brother
name like five different times and I
just keep dropping it dude it's just it
just it's just but it'll be I don't
remember if I want to see it because I
want to see how it translates with time
um
but not banjo wasn't just wasn't like a
fun game it was very goofy
awkward controlling he's not a
interesting character at all like
there's nothing interesting about banjo
in my opinion I feel like there's a lot
of other IP they can leverage if they
wanted to bring back do you think a
conquer game would do better than a
banjo game
um I think a copy game would do better
than bad looking that's my opinion
it's about today see the thing is that
they would have to be like you know how
I think banjo and Conquer and stuff can
all come back as like double A games
in my opinion yeah oh yeah hungry really
what a Cocker game you geyser
game will be bigger than the benzo game
bro oh my God I'm so hurt
I'm generally upset
okay Alex now you have to realize where
I'm coming from I was not a Nintendo guy
uh not a Nintendo guy I know rare
um has when I was bought by Xbox what
um
yeah like the one time I tried to play
conqueror was when they dropped that
rare replay some years back
I tried bro I couldn't play I I couldn't
get the room
all right so
I feel you I feel you I still disagree
and um you know I'm psychically cursing
you for uh saying conquer would do
better but it is it is
silver afro has a like he had a point
conquer has personality what is banjo's
personality
he's got Kazooie oh come on
tell me I'm wrong
how could was getting drunk at the
beginning of that game man
got a girl
he was like how do you know Kazooie
don't
worry this backpack man
is it isn't there a uh was it that I
can't remember the
the the female you know who has better
chance of doing better than banjo
Voodoo Vince no no I'm not gonna go that
far smaller because I remember that
Voodoo bridge I was the only person that
bought that yeah
all right let's let's get to the last
topic of the evening
we're gonna be talking about Xbox
if you play banjo I'm not watch yo hey
so much hate for banjo my homie Jamal
Lee said if I stream brands or I'll have
seven viewers I think you would have
more than seven fears okay 12. okay so
two
you know what I learned a long time ago
if you want to stream games
you set the title up
like a podcast and you talk about the
stuff in the podcast while you play
games why are you playing I guess yeah
so that's the only way hey your bone
slave says blinks time sweeper I would
prefer that over bad oh my God spoken
not here
I definitely play real I think it's red
false so you know I will play that over
you would play Red fall over Banjo
Kazooie
a remastered one like a remake of
Banjo-Kazooie yes a remake for the
ground up
well I actually finished RAV4 so
um
I would play it though just why does it
feel special a 2 000 Play Just that's
different that's different he's like
well I'm being bad I'm being bought
Cameo would be a dough remake because
Cameo was an underrated long game for
the 360. yeah on the rating game yep all
right so
Xbox uh apparently there could be a
games call uh so I did see did this
PlayStation was gonna be there
no I I haven't seen it I think I think
they they have something for like a
third party there but I don't think
they're themselves going to be there uh
two dollar Super Chat from Nintendo the
adult uh Nintendo domiotaku recourse a
better 3D platformer than bench I hate
you guys
how many times I've capped for record
recall is pretty good I love record was
pretty good it was pretty good
all right so let's get into this man
what first of all let's go let's go into
your expectations with Gamescom I do
think that Xbox
has so much content being made at all
times now that I don't know what they
would show at Gamescom they could show
DLC they could announce a game there's a
lot of potential things they can do at
Gamescom I don't know if they could do
none of that they can literally just
show up there with Starfield and
whatever they have coming out this year
and say go go nuts so what what what do
you guys expect from Gamescom in terms
of Xbox we'll start with uh kids movies
um I honestly don't have I don't know
even though they're going to Gamescom
it's not a press conference anymore so
when they usually just show up for like
a demo run
um there's really no expectations I
don't know what was the last thing they
announced or revealed at games time uh
com I'm not sure if it's still like that
big of a deal
um so I really don't really have
anything if anything it's gonna be like
a repeat of e3 some some games but I
don't think anything major at this point
they're in full Gear star filled with
people and cologne will be able to play
Star field which is going to be great
because it'll be closer to the launch
um
unfortunately maybe
um other than that I can't imagine
anything significant
I agree I I these super chats but I only
want to read it I two dollars I read it
okay you want me read it yeah
two dollar super chats from Godzilla
uh he said I play banjo more on Smash
than his own game it's crazy man you
guys can go out there and support banjo
on another damn platform but get banjo
any love on their own platform it
belongs to you guys you guys don't
deserve banjo you don't you don't
deserve banjo your banjo deserves better
it deserves are a lot better
you really play banjo addict yeah
you finished it back in the day
nice have you played it both of them
imported to the 360. Xbox One yes
did you play nuts and bolts no that's
the worst one in my opinion I never
played nothing I didn't even play that
one bro I ever tried oh my God it's been
so long since I played them uh I
probably wouldn't remember because I've
only beat it once like way back in the
day when it was on the n64. I never I've
beat on like the 360. so if I just
played it I did like the first three or
four Maps I would probably generally get
stuck on the later parts of the game now
because I don't remember everything
about that I think the last thing I
remember playing frequently is like the
the the graveyard map where there's a
bunch of great uh you know grave there's
a bunch of tombstones everywhere and
stuff like that so okay anyway we're
we're getting off track but we're
getting off track talk about Gamescom
games calm
yeah
um I'm nice move I'm not expecting
anything the last thing of any
significance I remember Xbox doing at
the Gamescom was showing the campaign
trailer for Gears
um five in 2019 because if you remember
2019 E3
for some reason they didn't show any
campaign footage at E3 they showed that
escape mode and pissed a lot of people
off including myself
so they decided to show the campaign
footage at Gamescom
that's the last time I've been showing
anything of any significance bro what
was it a couple years ago they had a
trebuchet man remember that thing uh
what game were they promoting
with that trebuchet
like dollar Taco what game were they
promoting showing off that trebuchet I
don't even remember it remember it was
horrible it was a waste of time so like
Smooth said they might
show some more force of Motorsports
stuff maybe show some Starfield stuff
but that's about it they ain't gonna
show nothing new I don't think they show
nothing new hold on if they have any new
announcements this year fans
opinion on this okay we going back in
time Fame
do you think
that Banjo-Kazooie would do better than
conquer
I need your opinion Fame
I hope to God that's who's on that
account I would assume so
Fame once again I read the skin
do you think that badge Kazooie will do
better
then conquer
you know just in case you know
Banjo-Kazooie
Fame do you think would do better than
conquer
huh he said hell no
the campground
hey you might be disappointed with the
answer uh attic oh my God he's sick
honka for the week
come on Addie you can't think banjo
would do better than conquer bro we're
moving on through it we're moving I'm
not fighting with you guys just to bring
you back to uh Gamescom the biggest
thing Xbox did at a Gamescom was um the
Tomb Raider thing the Tomb Raider
exclusivity
2015. they actually had a conference
yeah yep yeah
Quantum break they show Quantum break uh
some Tomb Raider stuff they yeah they
actually had a conference in 2015.
man I don't hear nobody say Xbox one had
games the first three years bro
I agree
which you know I think you know keep
your expectations in check but I would
expect some you know Game Pass
announcements I would expect some you
know maybe second party exclusives
coming to like Indies exclusively coming
to the platform yeah and then I would
expect some you know key games as a
service coming to uh the system uh you
probably expect that and then you know
they might throw you a curveball and
show you like some new Starfield
gameplay or something two dollar
supercharger Jax 82 last time I saw
banjo was in Smash Bros I'm done with
you guys we ain't talk about that no
more yeah we're about to end this anyway
uh because you know it is what it is man
because I I told Dory I'd get him out of
here by like 6 35-ish so we we're right
there
so let me put it in the time stance
because we're about to end this show
it's one hour and 10 minutes
all right so let's let's go in in the
show man what what what's going on with
smooth what what how that hurt yeah and
this sounds like it hurt what's going on
with smooth
um trying to put out maybe hopefully get
a video out uh in the next couple days
I've been trying to monitor this whole
APK D I was hoping they pull out a
decision soon because this thing needs
to end the facts um
I'm thinking about uh linking up with uh
uh doc doc I want to do a video
dedicated video or whatever maybe it'll
be on the next playing Xbox podcast
um just discussing
um you know Rogue allies since I've been
playing it a lot more
um
the other thing is we got play obviously
playing Xbox uh me and attic on every
Saturday uh lunch is on a weapon with
patreon
um but no I don't really you really got
to work on those ums
um
fortunately it's a bad habit uh
it's really a bad habit I feel you um
you know it's just words one of those um
things that you know because you said
that my next video is going to feature
zero a matter of fact it's gonna be
one
I'm gonna give myself two ums and a
that's the limit two arms an 11 minute
video okay two arms two arms all right
dirt
what's going on
um not much man I will probably have a
doc man podcast tomorrow I'm not sure
what I'm going to talk about and if he
gets 800 likes he's streaming Banjo
Kazooie all right yeah that's it yeah I
don't know about that one he said yeah
he said yeah
Hey listen I want them to watch the show
so I would not be sure Kazooie
um now that's about it bro you know
that's about it um
I'll have probably episode tomorrow like
like smoothie I was hoping some of some
because at first I heard people saying
that the judge was going to announce her
verdict today but obviously that didn't
happen
but we'll get it soon within the next
week most likely and um yeah man it's
gonna be a lot of fun so yeah I'm I'm
going to frame ent's uh podcast directly
after this
so stop by man yeah we uh oh that's over
there on level one Gaming's YouTube
channel definitely go with and check
that out normally I would rate them but
I want to get out a little early so dirt
can actually relax for
20 30 minutes before the show appreciate
it for coming through appreciate kid
smooth coming through uh we got 178
likes 422 people in the chat there's not
really anyone I could raid to because
unfortunately uh no one else has went
live like if you guys are content
creators like go into your your thing
and make it to where anyone can rage you
and if you don't feel like doing anyone
just make sure you put where we could
raise you because there'd be so many
opportunities where I don't really have
anyone to to raid uh but you know I get
that I could Sid you guys over there it
looks like but the show hasn't started
yet so go over there get some food get
some drinks and wait for fame show to
start uh you know we got 182 likes let's
get that 200 before the end of the show
man we about to end I know there is 18
of you people in this chat that haven't
liked that video yet don't don't play
with me don't play with me we give you
plenty of entertainment man we talked
about PlayStation nonsense for like for
like an hour it felt like but I
appreciate it for coming through and
until next week this is Lord addict Dirk
Gregory and kids move we're out of here